En este capítulo daremos el marco conceptual
para pensar en entornos informáticos
que se puede aplicar tanto a tu laptop
como escalar hasta supercomputadoras
al final de este capítulo
vas a entender el concepto fundamental de los recursos informáticos
y cómo se relacionan entre sí
entonces, ¿qué son los recursos informáticos? Básicamente,
son los componentes que conforman un sistema informático
tenemos la CPU o unidad central de procesamiento
que ejecuta la mayoría de las instrucciones; tenemos la memoria
o RAM, que almacena temporalmente los datos
y las instrucciones del programa
y tenemos las GPUs o unidades de procesamiento gráfico
diseñadas para renderizado gráfico
pero que también se pueden usar para tareas de cómputo de propósito general
que requieren mucho procesamiento en paralelo
como simulaciones científicas, análisis de datos o aprendizaje automático
estos recursos trabajan juntos para ejecutar programas
y cada uno tiene sus propias unidades de medida
por ejemplo, las unidades de CPU se miden en núcleos
y velocidad de reloj, mientras que la memoria se mide en bytes
en giga, mega y terabytes
para cada uno de nuestros problemas
vamos a necesitar un conjunto de recursos
para ejecutarlos
es crucial considerar los recursos necesarios para ejecutarlos
de forma eficiente; la ubicación donde se ejecutan los componentes del programa
y el ancho de banda de la infraestructura que los conecta
juegan un papel importante
en determinar el rendimiento general
por ejemplo, una GPU puede ser más rápida para calcular partes específicas
de nuestro programa, pero si cargar el programa en la memoria de la GPU
tarda más de lo que ahorramos
quizás sea más rápido usar la CPU directamente; ahora bien,
hablemos de cómo escalar recursos clásicos
tenemos dos enfoques: escalado vertical
y escalado horizontal; el escalado vertical implica aumentar
la potencia de un único recurso
como usar una CPU más potente o más memoria
dentro de un solo nodo físico
donde nodo es una unidad de un clúster de cómputo que encapsula múltiples
recursos; el escalado horizontal
implica agregar más recursos
como múltiples CPUs o GPUs
que trabajen juntos en un solo nodo o en múltiples nodos
ambos enfoques tienen sus propias ventajas
y desventajas, y la elección depende del caso de uso específico
y los requisitos; introduzcamos un nuevo tipo de recurso:
los recursos cuánticos; los recursos cuánticos procesan información cuántica
con una unidad de procesamiento cuántico o QPU; una QPU
es el sistema completo responsable
de aceptar un conjunto de instrucciones cuánticas ejecutables
o un quantum circuit y devolver
una respuesta precisa; esto significa
que la QPU incluye uno o más chips cuánticos,
por ejemplo un procesador cuántico de IBM
así como múltiples componentes adicionales
dentro de un refrigerador de dilución
que enfría el chip cuántico
como amplificadores cuánticos, electrónica de control
y la computadora clásica necesaria
para tareas como almacenar instrucciones
y formas de onda en memoria, acumular resultados
y la futura decodificación de corrección de errores
en general, los recursos cuánticos se miden
en términos de su calidad: la escala de fidelidad en capas
el número de qubits
y la velocidad: operaciones de circuit layer por
segundo, o CLOPS; hoy trataremos el chip cuántico
como una unidad de medida, de forma similar a cómo los sistemas de gestión de recursos
tratan las GPUs: no por el número de núcleos,
sino como unidades completas; ¿y qué hay del escalado?
Al igual que con los recursos clásicos, el escalado de recursos cuánticos puede
clasificarse también en vertical
y horizontal; el escalado vertical
sería aumentar el número de qubits por chiplet
o por chip
el escalado horizontal sería conectar chips
con acopladores o con interconexiones clásicas
con esa definición clara,
hablemos de la gestión de recursos
la gestión de recursos en infraestructura informática se refiere
al proceso de planificar,
asignar y controlar el uso de recursos computacionales
como CPU, memoria, almacenamiento
y ancho de banda de red para garantizar un uso
eficiente y efectivo de los recursos
puedes pensar en la gestión de recursos
como un juego multidimensional de Tetris donde los bloques
son los requisitos de tus trabajos,
y cada dimensión es una unidad de recurso; la tarea general
es encajar esos bloques de trabajo en el cubo
de todos tus recursos disponibles; la gestión de recursos
es una tarea muy compleja y distintos centros de cómputo implementan
diferentes estrategias para configurar su infraestructura
según las necesidades específicas de sus usuarios
para aplicar los conceptos que acabamos de aprender, vamos a usar
Slurm; Slurm es software de código abierto
para la gestión de recursos
para esta demostración,
tengo una configuración local con tres nodos virtuales
podemos obtener información sobre esos nodos
ejecutando el comando scontrol
tenemos dos particiones o grupos de nodos:
normal y quantum; la partición normal está compuesta por nodos
que solo tienen acceso a recursos clásicos
y la partición quantum tiene acceso a recursos cuánticos
primero ejecutemos el ejemplo simple
de "hello world" clásico con Slurm
primero necesitamos el propio programa "hello world".
Aquí está nuestro programa que simplemente imprime "hello
world".
Ahora necesitamos decirle al gestor de recursos
qué recursos necesitamos para ejecutar este programa
como comentamos, Slurm nos da una forma de especificar
todos los metadatos de un trabajo
mediante un script de shell
con algunas anotaciones específicas de Slurm
estas anotaciones te permiten especificar los requisitos de recursos,
parámetros de planificación y más.
Podemos revisar nuestro script de envío
y aquí tenemos la especificación de la partición,
cuántos nodos necesitamos, cuántas tareas por nodo vamos
a ejecutar, cuántas CPUs por tarea vamos a usar
y qué script queremos correr
y este es nuestro programa "hello world".
Para enviar nuestro trabajo a ejecución, solo necesitamos correr
un comando, que es sbatch,
y pasarle nuestro script como argumento
podemos revisar la cola de ejecución
y ver que nuestro programa "hello world" está corriendo
en la partición normal, en el nodo c-uno
una vez que el trabajo termina, podemos revisar los resultados
mirando el archivo de salida.
Y eso es todo.
También nos interesa usar recursos cuánticos,
así que vamos a crear un programa simple de "hello" con Qiskit.
Aquí está nuestro programa de Qiskit, que incluye todos los
pasos necesarios de creación del circuit,
optimización, ejecución y posprocesamiento.
Y aquí están todos los conceptos de programación que vimos:
quantum circuit, transpiler
y primitivas de Qiskit
ahora necesitamos crear el script de envío
igual que antes, pero aquí especificamos
los requisitos de recursos cuánticos
como ya especificamos los recursos
y la partición del clúster,
los recursos cuánticos disponibles
que usarán las primitivas de Qiskit
son los recursos asignados para ejecutar los circuitos cuánticos.
Ahora necesitamos ejecutar nuestro programa.
Y una vez que el trabajo termina, podemos revisar los resultados.
Y aquí está nuestro valor de expectación.
Y eso es todo en cuanto a la gestión de recursos;
en la siguiente sección vamos a hablar
sobre modelos de programación